promise to answer your mortgage
questions we're joined by Joe Bartlett a
mortgage broker who offers advice to
would-be homeowners as the home buyer
coach no less well coach I hope you're
ready to put us through our mortgage
pace is uh good to see you there Joe
let's get our first question then it
comes from Lee who asked this question I
know you you'll have heard all of them
an awful lot but this is on many
people's minds should I switch from a
Tracker mortgage to a fixed rate so if
you're on a Tracker I'm guessing your
rate is going up because it's following
the increase in interest rates but uh a
fixed rate well there as we'll discuss a
bit later on they're um they're quite
hard to get and they're getting higher
indeed yes so a Tracker mortgage is
linked to the bank of England base rate
so if this increases then so would your
payments uh you may prefer the security
of a fixed mortgage knowing your
mortgage payments will be fixed for a
set period of time
um but that said everyone's
circumstances are different and what's
best for you might not be best for the
next person so it will depend on
individual circumstances so just take us
through I mean ballpark some of the
rates so what would a Tracker rate be
what uh the base rates 2.25 if I
remember correctly so people are what
tracking at about 0.75 to 1.25 above
that
yes correct yes so you know for
when you're looking at the tracker rates
they might look quite appealing but the
thing that you have to consider is what
could happen to that rate if you do
choose to choose to go for that type of
mortgage or remain on that type of
mortgage
and as we're well let's discuss it now
through questions because I'm going to
talk more about fixed rates now we've
got this uh from Brian and this is about
timing so many people wondering what
precisely to do so Brian's saying my
mortgage is due for renewal
and I've lost the rest of the question
because my autoq's not turning over uh
my mortgage is due for Renewal soon is
it worth me trying to lock in a new deal
now
okay so I would say the sooner you can
talk to your mortgage advisor the better
they can weigh up the different options
and recommend the best option for you at
that time the issue that you have is if
you leave it too long at the moment it
could potentially mean that you're
paying more than you need to so it's
best sorting this out sooner rather than
later okay but how long can you lock it
in for I mean it depends when your
mortgage is due for Renewal and uh Brian
doesn't make that clear I mean it could
be some months away or it could be
pretty shortly
absolutely so with most lenders uh sorry
with most of my clients what I tend to
do is give them a call around six months
prior to when their mortgage fixed deal
is due to end and the reason for this is
a new mortgage application once that's
been accepted the mortgage offer is
usually valid for a six-month period so
you might be able to do something
um earlier than you think
and so it's valid for six months so
people I mean people who locked in what
three four five months ago must be
feeling pretty pleased with themselves
now
yeah potentially so yeah as long as they
can complete in time absolutely
well we've got a follow-on question from
Mike this fits rather nicely then I
completed my application to remortgage
and I'm just waiting for an answer could
the bank remove the offer now completed
the application presumably that means I
think Mike doesn't make clear though
that both sides then haven't signed it
off offers can be withdrawn can't they
well yes it will depend on what stage of
the remortgage process they're in so if
they are in the middle of the
application lenders can potentially
decline
um for say something like a down
valuation on the property or they're not
happy with a certain aspect of the
mortgage application
um if the mortgage has actually offered
then the only way they can really revoke
this is if there's been a you know
material change to a change in
circumstances this could be that the
property value has dropped since the
initial valuation was taken place uh or
perhaps personal changes like a job loss
increased debt missed payments that
could be grounds for uh revoking the
mortgage offer ah but crucially grounds
were evoking the offer are not that your
other rates have gone up the the rate
that you've offered this client is no
longer available
no so if you had a mortgage
um offer agreed then you will receive
the rate that is on the offer
um as I said unless there have been
material changes which means that the
offer needs to be revoked well just on
that I mean that other point you make
one of the grounds for withdrawing
offers that house prices have fallen
well if you've had your valuation who
can tell you need another valuation then
don't you
well what a lot of lenders do is do an
automated valuation they've got you know
built into their systems daily updated
uh valuations so if they see a drastic
change that means the mortgage is um or
the property is no longer suitable
security for the mortgage that could
potentially be grounds for revoking a
mortgage offer I see well uh Tom's
question coming up next follows on from
that and Tom quite uh well I suppose
straightforwardly asks this is now the
right time to be selling your house and
that's it that's the 64 000 well much
more on that dollar question isn't it
it's your judgment on what's the
direction of travel for house prices
yeah it's a very good question um and
one that I've been receiving a lot
recently so selling your house is always
a very stressful experience and now is
you know certainly no different
um there's a lot of uncertainty around
the housing market house values uh which
is understandable
um again I mean with most of these
questions it will depend on your
personal circumstances
um you know you may need to move due to
a growing family
um I always think that the best way to
look at it is you know the best time to
move for you not necessarily the market
um and it's also important to remember
that the property that you are buying
will be in the same Market as the one
that you're selling in
um but you don't want I I hear what you
say it's individual circumstances of
course and houses are for living in
they're not for for bartering they're
not financial instruments but uh
nevertheless you don't want to get
saddled with an overpriced house you go
into negative equity because house
prices fall and you're stuck with a
large fixed rate
yeah that's very true
um like like I say it's there's no
perfect time to sell and
it will come down to whether you need to
sell
um and what your circumstances are so
you know if you drop relocation
um you know if you're coming to the end
of your mortgage deal you know the end
of your mortgage terms sorry
um you may be in a position where you
need to sell so you know every every
customer is going to be is going to be
completely different but what's your
advice be to someone who said uh right
okay I hear you need to sell Gotta Move
um you know for jobs or family or
whatever but my view on house prices is
they're going to fall so I'm going to
cash in the equity I've got in my
existing property and then I'm going to
rent for a few months and see which way
the wind blows
yeah and that may be very well some of
the um some of the opinions of um of
current sellers and buyers
um you'll need to weigh it up there's no
right or wrong answer you know look at
the worst case scenarios of both options
so you know let's just say that um house
prices stay low
um and you're put in a position where
you need to sorry the rates stay high
and you're in a position where you're
renting and the rents increase because
of the increased
um rates so landlords are then passing
it down onto their tenants
um you could find yourself you know a
year or two later spending nine hundred
thousand pounds 1200 pounds a month on
rent when you could have buyed gone for
a longer term fixed product to secure
the payments and know exactly what you
can you know know exactly what you're
paying month by month that's an
important consideration I got a question
from I suspect uh a first time buyer how
is a first-time buyer expected to buy a
property now with mortgage rates
increase increasing our ladiness and
property price is still going up but
what support is there that's a question
coming from Emma
so we have just seen the stamp Duty
changes for first-time buyers which
really helped with The Upfront costs of
moving
um also there are still some really
great schemes available for first-time
buyers such as shared ownership uh the
fast home scheme help to buy although
that is ending shortly
um but yeah there are still very very
good schemes available
um for first-time buyers
there's also an icer isn't there which
can help with house purchases
absolutely yes and it was the help time
sorry the help to buy ISO which has now
been replaced with the lifetime Isa
which can really help boost your um
booster deposit
and um what about uh just tell us the
the stamp Duty Cuts or the the increases
they're different they're higher rates
for first-time buyers just talk us
through what the numbers are
sure so it was three hundred thousand
that was the cap this has been increased
now to 425 000 so if you're buying below
that you won't pay stamp Duty on the
purchase
but does that apply the 425 then does
that say you buy somewhere more
expensive 500 600 000 pounds does the
first four two five then not count when
it comes to stamp Duty
so what would happen is the amount
you're buying up to 425
000 pounds would be exempt from stamp
Duty and then depending on the purchase
price you'll have brackets so the first
amount after 425 000 will be a
percentage of tax payable
um it's always best to speak to a Tax
Advisor on this as a mortgage broker I
can't get tax advice so always best to
speak to your to your Tax Advisor well
all your other advice is really good I
can say and not just on the issue of
shared ownership then the proportion
which you don't own you're paying rent
on and presumably that's going to go up
funnily enough I actually own a shared
ownership property and I bought it
fairly recently
um
and it was obviously one of the
questions that I asked because I was
concerned about rent going up and for me
the reason for buying a shared ownership
property was you know I wanted to get
back on the housing market sorry that
you know the property ladder and it
meant that I could buy the property with
a very low deposit
um
the last month I received a letter from
them saying that they're going to be
putting the rent up and it's gone up by
seven pounds a month so you know I can
manage that the help to buy scheme and
the housing associations really are
there to to help you you know they're
not there to to sting you unnecessarily
okay so they're the good guys
um question from question from Jeff and
some of it I think we we covered Joe but
uh just mention it again Jeff asks um
how can I say for a mortgage when rent
is already so high and this is the kind
of Catch-22 people get caught in they
just can't afford to save anything
because they're they're renting and and
it costs so much
very true yeah so you know forget what's
happening now it's never easy to save
for a deposit especially when you're
paying a huge amount on rent
um the good news is that some lenders
can still consider a five percent
deposit in some situations
um yeah also I'll bring you back to the
various schemes such as shared ownership
so as mentioned it's a very good way to
pay a less smaller deposit
um than buying normally got uh the
mortgage and housing expert Joe Bartlett
here with me answering all your
questions that you've been sending in to
us all day with your concerns about
mortgages house prices and the rest so
let's uh continue with a question from
James uh James asking about the interest
rate Rises and we know that there are
more to come the bank of England
signaled that very clearly today James
asks is this likely to cause the housing
market to crash and house prices to drop
well Joe you know it's Crystal Ball time
isn't it but um what are the lessons
from history when interest rates went up
well I qualified as a mortgage broker in
2015 so I missed the 2008 recession so
up until fairly recently you know we've
been spoiled with um with great interest
rates and all of the conversations that
I've had with with customers previously
have always been very positive you know
look at how much money we can
potentially save you
um that has changed with regards to the
housing market
um it's it's too soon to judge
um all I can comment on at the moment is
my personal day-to-day observations and
a lot of my customers are still actively
trying to find properties some are
struggling to have as offers accepted
um which shows there's still a large
demand in the market
um it's very difficult to judge what
will happen in the uh in the future and
that's the point you're making there Joe
isn't it that interest rates and the
price of borrowing money it's just one
factor in the value of Housing and one
of the biggest determinants is of course
as you touched on their supply and
demand and the fact is is we've known
for many years now we're not building
enough properties and the population
keeps growing we can all work out what's
happening
absolutely yeah I agree
um you know it does help that they do
have these schemes there are Builders
out there that are offering um you know
that are you know offering the schemes
as well so
um the supply and the demand
thing has been it's been very difficult
for buyers up until recently you know
the amount of customers that I've had
that have been trying to buy a property
for the last few months and have just
had you know no luck whatsoever whether
or not it's coming up against a cash
buyer or you know being outbid
um it has been a crazy Market
and those of different Generations uh
from you Joe I mean I'm a year or two
older than you
um but we regard um we regard six
percent interest rates says my goodness
me that sounds really cheap I mean you
know I bought many many moons ago my
first property and I was paying 15
percent
crazy isn't it absolutely yeah we have
been absolutely spoiled with um with
interest rates you know I remember doing
interest rates at one point you know
below two percent and it's just it's
just incredible
um but they weren't gonna last forever
um and now appears to be the time when
things are likely to change okay here's
here's our last question and Joe you've
been uh brilliant so far yeah I know
you're going to keep this up um with uh
Elaine's question who wants to know this
some should I use my savings to pay off
my mortgage or sit tight and wait to see
what happens with interest rates next
year and that's alluding to the point
isn't it just because the prediction
that interest rates may go to six
percent doesn't mean to say they
necessarily will I mean they could go
higher but they could well come in under
that
absolutely absolutely it's a very
interesting question so you may be able
to counteract the potential rise in
payments by reducing the mortgage amount
but it's important to check with your
existing lender whether or not there are
any early repayment charges as you may
be charged for paying off you know a
large lump sum off the mortgage
um so that's the first call you need to
make
yeah and uh also I mean but if you are
in a position it sounds like Elaine is
in a fortunate position the idea of you
could pay off some of your mortgage
depending on what product you've got
presumably
absolutely so many mortgage lenders
um and it's important to check with your
individual lender but many do give you
the ability to overpay by 10 of the
outstanding Mortgage Balance each year
so it might be worth you know utilizing
your savings to to do that
um rather than paying off a large lump
sum and potentially incurring costs
well Joe we uh owned by a coach we have
had a proper workout thank you very very
much indeed some great advice to to
ponder and to take away of this Joe
Bartlett there thank you very much